i hope everything's
going well in your life with the
pandemic and everything um
i would imagine the only positive thing
about the pandemic for you
is you can actually go to the grocery
store wearing a mask
and no one will know who you are
yeah yeah that is uh that is true
but uh unfortunately like you don't
always wear a mask you know like when
i'm
getting into my car you know you don't
always wear a mask and
that's that's where the sneaky
paparazzi's uh
gets you you know so no but it it
my my girlfriend loves it she loves that
aspect of it she's like i don't have to
wear makeup i don't have to worry
like you don't have to wear makeup
anyways and you definitely don't have to
worry so
so before i jump into why i get to talk
to you today i have a few fun more fun
questions that i've been asking of
everyone
uh what tv show would you love to guest
star on
oh
[Music]
good question
oh i can see you're actually giving it
some real thought yeah hmm
i get the cast myself that's a great
thing the first season of handmaid's
tale
got it what have you guys been binge
watching
um well right now i've been studying
spanish so i'm watching
uh a bunch of spam right i'm in the
middle of watching el chapo right now
is it spanish because of an upcoming
role no i just
it was sort of my uh my pandemic mission
i was like i don't i've been wanting to
learn spanish for a long time and i was
like if i don't
[ __ ] do it now i'm never going to do
it so i've just
been at it and i actually can speak a
little bit of spanish now
really yeah yeah amigo
[Laughter]
i want to say congratulations that's
awesome yeah thanks yeah
uh so jumping into why i get to talk to
you today uh i would imagine you get
offered a bunch of scripts and a bunch
of projects
um what was it about this this script
and this movie that said i want to do
this
well actually the way this originated
was that me and numi um her
old friends we actually went to high
school in sweden together really i did
not know that
yeah um we weren't friends back in
high school but you know we knew of each
other we were part of very different
cliques
you know she was the hardcore theater
clique and i was more
like a little hip-hop crew you know
and uh swedish hip-hop crew and um
uh but then we became good friends over
the course of our careers and we both
you know were over here and
um i think we both knew each other
originally from like stage work in
sweden
like uh both doing pretty like heavy uh
theater stuff in in the first years of
our careers in sweden and stockholm and
gothenburg
and um and we you know we had a
few we had a great interaction
in child 44. um you know that movie
didn't turn out the way we were
we thought it was going to but you know
we had some great experiences
acting-wise in it
and especially in particular me and her
and
so so we were just kind of plotting and
scheming and we're like let's find
something to do together
and and then we found the script and we
loved it
we loved like the core of it and we felt
like it needed work
and then we were trying to find
something that was going to someone to
do a pass on a director
with the strong vision and
she didn't let it go she stuck with it
and and then she found yuval and yuval
told her that you know he told her
like 50 of the script is great you're
great
joel's great the other 50 is [ __ ] but
i'm in
okay and then and then he took it from
there and he really elevated
the script he took it to another place
and um
and completely reworked and actually i
shifted roles i was originally
um when me and we had the first
iteration of the script i was going to
play the husband
um and then and then you with the aval's
take
he really wanted me to play thomas and
um
originally in the original version you
could not identify thomas
as um anything else than american he had
like a perfect american accent
so he was more like a chameleon in that
sense um
so you've all completely shifted the
emphasis
of of the film it he made it feel much
less like a world war ii
kind of holocaust repercussion kind of
movie
and much more something about a uh
of a sexual trauma you know sexual
violence
and and uh so he replaced it much more
i feel like uh the the the film you know
finds itself in a corner of the
discussion of what's going on and the
movement that's
uh been going on and uh and i think
it comes at it from a little bit of a
different angle and
i think it is a becomes a great
you know piece of that conversation
listen um you do great work in it
um i'm very curious when when you're
playing a role like this
or you're playing a role that causes
maybe for a little bit of intense
emotions
are you able to leave the character
you're playing on set
every day and become back you know go
back into being joel
when you get home or does a piece of the
character you're playing kind of always
stick with you until you rap
maybe even after you rap yeah it was um
usually yes even when i've done intense
stuff before
and and i figure it's usually like this
when you play a character
that gets to you know pour their heart
out
um i usually go
from set or from the stage as a happy
person you know
even though you're going through these
like convulsive experiences
um but if you're allowed to go through
them
you go you come out on the other side
and and you've gone through some sort of
catharsis it's the same thing as when
you have a big fight and you're crying
and
uh you know afterwards you feel kind of
serene and you and you you feel good
you feel very open and and you're
susceptible to love and you feel loving
when you're when you hold on to
everything and also when something is
done to
you it's a lot different and i i wasn't
expecting how much
i was gonna get affected by this but i
got really affected by it
and um i'm usually very
conscious of the energy the
spirit on set and i i i get out i get a
lot out of
being a co-creator of like a generous
warm environment on set
where you know you solve differences in
a good way and
and you know people are laughing and
even if you're doing you know serious
[ __ ] it's
uh it's with a warm generous spirit
um i wasn't able to do that at all on
this movie
um i was i got really agitated
i got into big fights with uball on set
we were screaming at each other
i can't remember ever having that
experience before
and you know it was i was just sitting
on set for hours on end being tied up
and you know and
and he was i agree with all of his
uh you know directing instincts um but
while they were happening to me
uh you know because my my arms were
getting tied in a way that like
i was literally like bleeding from my
arms because the ropes were like digging
into
my wrists in this way and um and and i
was getting like sores in the
in in the corners of my my mouth because
the gag was like
you know tied so tight you know so
you've all had some really
strong bdsm uh you know like his bdsm
skills are you know very strong
and uh and i will always was he the one
who actually was doing all the time
he would yeah oh then yeah it's not hard
enough you know like
uh and for sure he took some pleasure
out of that you know
and that is without a doubt um no but it
it it really affected me and um and it
took me
uh a few days to uh to let it go and
and i was i felt really
yeah i was um i felt pretty frail
and uh and worn out when we were done
with it and and it was you know it was a
really short intense shoot
and i told to myself you're never gonna
do a series of something where
this is the dynamic this is like
something you do for a few weeks
and and then it's uh yeah you lose your
mind
it actually ended up probably being the
toughest thing
emotionally that i've done yeah i can't
imagine because
they're and i don't like talking
spoilers but there's a lot of scenes of
you
let's be honest a lot of scenes have you
tied up and uh that's a lot of the movie
and uh i can't imagine um going through
that myself
you know experiencing that especially
because people don't realize
making a movie is you know you could be
on set 12 hours yeah
the thing is also what's really
interesting is that even though you know
that this is a film and this is uh this
is a job
that we're doing and this is part of
being doing this job is being tied up
and being beaten and screamed at
but your body doesn't know that your
body is just suffering
the abuse and then it has a response to
it
as if it has been abused and and then
that in turn
infects your your thoughts and your
emotions
so it you literally go through a process
of actually being abused and um yeah so
it was
it was tough but interesting i'm really
glad i did it and
and i was very happy with the results i
really felt like the
you know it came out in the performance
i did not have to like search for
anything
everything was just right there on the
surface and accessible on like the first
take of every scene it was like it was
just there you know
no completely it was cool did you ever
reach the point though
where you had you know your arms tied up
behind you
did you ever reach the point where
you're like look we're not tying up my
arms today
like i'm just going to pretend that the
arms are you know back here or was
was it always you had you know what i
mean you were always going for the
realism
yeah no i mean there might have been uh
i'm sure that at some point you know
when we were just doing a close-up
somewhere
uh that i i don't really need them tied
here you know um
and i found those little uh moments of
breathing room but um i could also
feel while we were going through it even
though i was pissed off about it and
and um i didn't like someone screaming
at me
at the same time as i was being um
you know in physical pain and i
i felt you know i also knew that this is
good
and and there is this little masochistic
side of uh
i think of any good actor that uh you do
want to go through it because you also
you really want that performance and um
and
nothing is more important than that
completely i mean look your work shines
through in the film
um uh listen i know i only have so much
time with you i am a huge fan of for all
mankind
i love the show um i definitely want to
know i know you guys were filming season
two and you had to
pause because of covid um and then i
know that filming started back up have
you wrapped on season two yet
no so i have two days left um i think we
have about 10 days of shooting in total
i've shot like four days since we came
back and um yeah we're about to
to get it all in the can and uh
hopefully it'll it'll come out
in the end of this year beginning of
next and uh
yeah season two is sick it's really
we're taking it to another level like
this show
like i for people that like the dig the
show like i am
so stoked to show like the second and
then hopefully the third season because
you don't really understand the grand
vision of this show
until you come a little bit deeper into
it and like the grand vision of the show
is [ __ ] epic and especially for any
you know sci-fi fans you know it goes
places
it really goes i'm sure that apple would
have loved to start you know sort of at
season three
um because that's where it really goes
into that other place
um but i love that this show just like
kind of takes its time and builds its
way and
and maybe it'll take a little more time
for for it to find an audience
uh it still feels like the awareness of
the show
is not where we want it to be and and i
hope that the the word of mouth from the
people that love it is going to start to
build because
i personally feel like the writing is
excellent and
the grand vision of the show is so
[ __ ] dope
like as a fan i would love it you know
no i
was going to say listen i'm basically
out of time with you i could spend the
whole interview talking about for all
mankind
which when the season comes back i
really do want to talk again yeah for
sure
i mean like i i really but that's the
thing that um i think that the people
that haven't seen it really
the writing the production design the
acting
everything about the show is just so
well done
you know well i'm glad you see it um
and uh and i can't wait for you to see
season two i really i really can't
i really hope that apple uh really
supports it because
ron moore is a [ __ ] genius and you
know
also matt wolpert and ben adivi um
they're [ __ ] excellent yeah no no
it's it's uh
i'm all in so listen you got to do other
interviews but when the show comes back
hopefully we can talk and go
more deep into the yeah let's nerd out
on it yeah i know for sure hey listen um
congrats on everything uh have a
fantastic day
can't wait to see suicide squad always a
pleasure talking to you man